Hi, welcome back. Now, we've talked
about risk and value. Let's turn our
attention to trading costs for an
obvious reason. As investors, we need to
earn higher returns in the market. But
those higher returns will be after
trading costs. Now, you say, how big can
trading costs be? Especially in a world
where we live with online trading and a
trade can cost you as little as $6 a
piece. I think we might be missing large
pieces of what actually goes into
trading costs. You're right. Some of it
is of course that brokerage cost and
that cost is decreased over time, but
you also have a cost coming from the
spread between bid prices and ask
prices. In other words, the price at
which you can buy an asset and the price
which you can sell the same asset at the
same point in time are different. That
difference is called a bid ask spread.
The third is in the process of trading
you can actually affect the price called
the price impact. And finally to the
extent that you say hey if I waited and
broke my trades down wouldn't the cost
be lower? Maybe but there's an
opportunity cost. So waiting wait by
waiting you might reduce your returns or
not be able to trade at all. So let's
take a look at each of those costs.
Starting with the trading cost track.
There's very generic evidence that there
is a trading cost track and as as I
describe the evidence you might say
really we know that money managers trade
to get a profit from trading and if you
take the total return that an active
money manager makes that return can be
broken down into a return given the risk
they take on minus plus the return they
get from active trading the the choices
they bring to the process the stocks
they pick minus trading costs
Now, we'll talk about disentangling
these three pieces much later in this
class, but we do know conclusively that
the average active money manager
underperforms the market by about 1%.
And since these active average active
money managers cut across the spectrum,
value, growth, trading, investing, you
could argue that that 1% is just a
measure of the collective trading cost
they face because you can't make it
back. If you know because you're talking
about something that is pretty much the
entire market, there is a pretty
substantial trading cost. If that
doesn't convince you about the relevance
of trading cost, let me give you another
sad but true story. One of the most
renowned services in the US is a service
called Value Line. It's not as widely
used anymore, but there's a point in
time where if you're a value investor to
learn more about a company, you
subscribe to Value Line. And there was a
single page on each company, which
compressed a surprisingly large amount
of data on that page. And Value Line
actually was renowned for putting out
what were called timeliness ranks on
companies. And timeliness one were the
stocks that they said would go up the
most and timeliness five, the stocks
they thought that they felt would go
down the most. In fact, one of the
biggest sales pitches for Val and was a
graph that showed that over time that
timeliness one choices would have vastly
outperformed the timeliness five stocks.
At least on paper, it looked like
following value line would have made you
a very rich person. Now, Valine must
have believed their own hype because
they started a real fund to do what they
were telling people to do. In other
words, invest in their timeliness one
stocks. And in this graph you can see
the difference in returns between the
returns on paper the red line and what
their actual fund that was trying to do
what they were telling people to do by
the timeliness one stocks delivered his
returns. So they're very average fun in
fact it got shut down saying what
accounts for the difference there's many
a slip between the cup and the lip. It's
easy to make money on paper much more
difficult to do so in practice. Why?
because execution, transactions cost and
other issues all get into play. So let's
talk more about trading costs. Let's
start with a bit spread. You go back 30,
40, 50 years, you wanted to trade a
stock. There was a dealer or a market
maker on the floor of the exchange who
set the spread. You're saying no, but
what goes into that spread? The first is
the dealer has to cover the cost of
holding inventory of shares that they
hold while they're waiting for somebody
to buy. So the cost of holding
inventory. The second is the cost of
processing the orders themselves.
Especially in the days before computers,
there was a manual proc processing
process that required time and effort.
And the third is if you're a market
maker or dealer, you worry about the
fact that you might be trading against
somebody who has inside information,
better information than you do.
Inventory, cost of processing orders,
cost of trading with more informed
investors. Keep that all in mind because
that spread has to be large enough to
cover the cost and yield a reasonable
profit with the dealer or the market
maker. Now, this all leads into the
question of why bid ass spreads vary
across companies and sometimes vary
across time. If you look at publicly
traded stocks, the bid assass spread you
will see on individual stocks varies
across stocks. Now to standardize and
compare the spread, you have to divide
by the current price. So if you have a
stock that's trading at a $10 price with
a bid as spread of 50, that's a 5%
bid as spread.5 divided by the $10. If
you have a $1 stock with a 25cent bid
ass spread, that's a 25%
bid ass spread. If you look at bid
spread standardized across stocks, here
are the things that seem to drive the
differences across stocks. First is
obvious more liquid stocks, stocks with
a lot more trading on them tend to have
lower bit assets. Second, ownership
structure seems to happen. Stocks with a
lot of institutional ownership tend to
have higher bid assets than stocks with
less institutional ownership holding all
else constant. riskier stocks tend to
have higher bid assass spreads. The as
the price level goes up, the spread
seems to decrease as a percentage of the
price. And to the extent that you have
more transparent information about a
company or better corporate governance,
the bid spreads tend to be larger for
companies where information is more
opaque or corporate governance less
trustworthy. And finally, market
microructure matters. If you have a
stock that in the old days used to be
off the exchange, you had to go through
a dealer, the spreads tended to be
larger. Those are all factors driving
spreads, but there's a lot of noise in
the relationship. So with that in place,
let's talk about difference in spread
across US stocks. This is from a very
old study, and I'm sure that the
percentage numbers are there. The levels
have changed, but the overall finding
probably hasn't. In this study, you you
know they broke down stocks based on
market cap from smallest to largest and
looked at the bid ass spread as a
percentage of the price. First notice
the average stock price for the smallest
companies much lower than the average
stock price for the largest companies
458 versus 5240.
But the bid aspirate as a percentage of
the price is much higher the smallest
companies 6.55%
as opposed to half a percent. If you
have an investment philosophy that leads
you to invest in smaller companies, this
has to be part of the calculus. Higher
cost through higher bid aspirates. Now,
if you look deeper at the variation in
spreads across US stocks, lower price
stocks have substantially higher
spreads. Something I mentioned earlier,
stocks with higher trading volume have
lower spreads. And as insider holdings
increase, spreads seem to go up. Perhaps
because you worry about trading with
those insiders.
Now the data on spreads in other equity
markets is starting to come in and for
the most part spreads in other markets
especially emerging markets tend to be
larger than spreads in the US but the
key driver seems to be liquidity as
liquidity has improved in the Chinese
and the Indian market spreads have
decreased. So spreads are on the move as
liquidity changes over time.
Final point, and this is something that
equity investors might view as good
news, but we'll talk about how
potentially it could be affecting how
much you can make as an investor. If you
look at spreads over time in the US,
it's undeniable that spreads have
decreased over time, sometimes for
market microstructure reasons, sometimes
because of more liquidity. And this is
across the board. Even the smallest
stocks in the US have more, you know,
more liquidity and and smaller spreads
than they used to. Again, a factor in
what kind of philosophies might work now
as opposed to 30 or 40 years ago.
Now, why is a bid as spread a factor in
investment philosophies? If you have an
investment philosophy that leads you to
invest in stocks that have
disproportionately large bid ass
spreads, you might have great returns on
paper and then once you start investing,
you might find much lower returns
because the spreads eat away into it.
Let me give you a very simple example,
one that we're going to come back and
talk about more in the context of value
investing.
Uh about 40 years ago, Devontton Taylor,
you know, Taylor of course is legendary
behavioral econ economist know looked at
losing stocks. Stocks that had lost the
most during the course of a year and
they tried out a strategy buying the
biggest losers every year and holding
them for the next two years, the next
five years. And they found that the
biggest losers, the stocks that had the
worst returns in the previous year
tended to be the best stocks to hold
over the next five. Great evidence for
contrarian investing, right? But it
turned out that the stocks that came in
as the biggest loser stocks were often
very low price stocks, many trading at
less than a dollar. Putting in a price
constraint reduce the returns. And in
fact, if you broaden the bid ass spread
that you'd have to pay investing in
these stocks, those excess returns start
to disappear. We have to be realist as
investors. If you have investment an
investment philosophy that leads you
away from the largest, most liquid
stocks, that's perfectly okay as long as
you're factoring in this particular cost
that's going to come with that strategy.
Let's look at a second and often related
cost. Now often when you look at a
market price, you assume you can buy at
that price and sell at that price even
if you brought in the spread. But the
process of trading itself can cause a
price impact. Why? Because markets might
not be completely liquid. You try to buy
a 100,000 shares in a stock that is only
a couple of hundred,000 shares traded
every day, you will push up the price in
the process of buying the shares. You
try to sell those same shares, you can
push down the price.
So one reason is a liquidity effect and
if it's a liquidity effect it should
dissipate right after your trading stops
over the course of the next week next
day the next days next week it should go
away but there's another reason you
tried to buy a 100,000 shares in a stock
where there's not that much traded right
you know the the signal you're sending
to the rest of the market he or she must
know something I don't people worry
about the information behind your trade
That price impact comes from the fact
that if you're more informed and you're
buying because good things are going to
happen, people are going to push up the
price as you try to buy and that effect
is not going to go well. Liquidity and
information.
Whatever the reasons are, price impact
also can reduce returns. Because if
you're investing in companies where you
have push up the price as you buy and
push down the price as you sell, your
actual returns are going to be are going
to trail the returns you saw on paper.
You see how big can the price impact be?
This is again from a very old study.
It's a study that kind of captures a
liquidity effect. What this study looked
at was big block trades. In those days,
block trades came on the floor of the
exchange. And what happens if you were
able to invest at the time of the block
trade?
Block rate comes on the floor. There's a
price impact, right? It's temporary. If
you can buy at that low price and the
price recovers quickly, you're going to
make an excess return. So, this study
looked at what you could make as returns
from buying after a block trade. And it
concluded you could get rich if you
could buy almost instantaneously. So you
look at the zero that is if you can
trade instantaneously. And the larger
the block the more money you can make.
But here's the downside. You wait 2
minutes, 3 minutes, 5 minutes, your
returns are gone. What this study
illustrates is how liquid markets are.
There's a block trade effect but it very
quickly dissipates. Now I have to point
out that this study looked primarily at
large liquid companies blocked rates and
much smaller less liquid stocks might
have a longer impact but the bottom line
is a pure liquidity impact is tough to
exploit as an investor.
Now if you look at the total trading
costs which includes bidash spreads and
the price impact clearly it's much
greater for small companies opposed to
large companies. It's much greater for
much larger blocks and small blocks. And
here is a place we can start to think
about why you as a small investor might
sometimes have an advantage over a large
investor.
As a small investor, you might not have
access to some of the special things
large investors do, but they have a much
bigger price impact than you do. A
Fidarity Mellin might not be able to
trade on a small co company. Even if
they think it's undervalued because the
price impact they have, you might be
able to do that. So trading cost can cut
both ways depending on small and large
investors depending on the kind of cost.
So as you look at your investment
philosophy and the strategies that
emerge from it, it behooves you to see
what types of stocks come in as
investments. Are they small, lightly
traded companies or large liquid
companies, the effect of trading costs
are much greater if you have an
investment philosophy that requires that
you trade quickly. Little later in this
class, we're going to talk about trading
on information. You often have to trade
within a minute of something happening.
There your costs are going to be higher
because you don't have the luxury of
breaking your trades down. And generally
speaking, larger portfolios, the price
impact effect at least is going to be
much larger than with smaller
portfolios. One of those strange places
where being a small investor can give
you an advantage over a large investor.
There's a third component to trading
cost that we often don't think about
because the reaction that people have
when you talk about block trades and
price impact say hey I want to just wait
and break my trades down and do it over
a period of time. Yeah, you can do that
but there can be a cost to waiting. What
is that cost to waiting? One is if you
wait the price might go up while you
wait. Let's say you think a stock is
undervalued and you decide to buy it
over a week rather than right away. Over
that week, stocks might rise while
you're waiting, it eats away into your
returns. In fact, they might rise so
much that you might not be able to trade
because by the time you get around to
doing it, the prices become too high.
So, if there there is a cost to waiting
in some in some strategies and if
there's a cost to waiting, you can't
afford to. You have to take the higher
trading costs because you have no
choice. So, here are the determinance
the cost of waiting. First is what kind
of information are you sitting on? If
your valuation assessment was was based
on general public information, you can
afford to wait. You think a company's
undervalued because you estimated the
cash flows, you did an intrinsic
valuation. Well, that's what you think.
It's not going to affect other people's
trades. In contrast, if you think a
stock is undervalued, but you think an
earnings because you think an earnings
report is going to come out tomorrow,
it's much better than expected
information. You can't afford to sit on
that. So first is what kind of
information is driving your investment
philosophy. Second is how active is the
market for information? If you're in a
market or with or you're investing in a
company where there are hundreds of
analysts tracking the company and tens
of thousands of traders, news is going
to get out. You got to trade much more
quickly. The third is what kind of
investment philosophy do you have? If
your philosophy is stocks are
undervalued and that you're willing to
wait for a long period for them to be
fixed, you can afford to wait. It's not,
you know, your opportunity is not going
to go away just because you waited 3
days or 5 days. And finally, it turns
out that momentum based strategies
have a much greater waiting cost, right?
Momentum based strategies, you're buying
something that's going up. So if you
wait, it continues to go up. It eats
away at your returns. contrarian
strategies waiting might actually make
your returns better because while you
wait the stock might continue to move in
the wrong direction at least from your
perspective. So you've got bid ass
spreads higher for low small companies
higher for lower price dogs. You've got
you've got price impact much greater for
less liquid companies. You got the cost
of waiting varies across philosophies.
Let's talk about trading cost on real
assets. Okay. Smallest transactions cost
in the real asset sphere tends to be in
commodities because they're
standardized. Gold, silver, diamonds,
iron ore, etc. They come in standardized
units. There's no need for an expert to
come in and check them. With residential
real estate, we know the costs are
significant because of the structure of
real estate. In the US, you can often
end up giving up 5 to 6% of the value of
an asset in the process of trading it.
There's some pressure on those numbers.
They're starting to come down,
especially on large real estate
transactions, but that's a cost. With
fine art collectibles, commissions are
even higher. Why? because there are far
fewer intermediaries in the process,
right? And also the products are not
standardized. You might have a Picasso
very different from a different Picasso.
So what do you do? You have to hire an
expert. Experts are expensive. So
transactions costs are in every
investment class and they're often much
greater outside the financial asset
class than among financial assets.
One final point that I want to talk
about in the context of cost that we
don't often factor in is taxes. Let me
start with an obvious statement. As
investors, we get to spend after tax
money, not pre-tax money. So, how much
how much difference can taxes make. I
have um you know a data set of stock
returns going back to 1928. And in this
graph, here's what I did. I looked at
what uh know what $1,000 I'm sorry $100
invested in 1927 would be worth today
given the compounding effect. $100
invested in 1927 would be worth
$983,000.
Astonishing, right? But that's because
you've been in a very successful equity
market for almost a century. You take
that same money and you bring in the tax
effect. Look at the drop off. This is
assuming that at the end of every year
your trade will talk about turnover
effects. If you have to sell your stocks
and buy them again, you have to pay full
taxes. And I've factored in the taxes
depending on the year based on what
corporate what individual tax rates have
been in the US. You lose almost 80% of
your money. That's an more than 80% of
your money. That's an astonishing drop
off, right? But let's talk about what it
is that drives differences in tax effect
across different investment
philosophies/strategies.
If your investment philosophy leads you
to buy stocks which pay high dividends
historically in the US, the tax rates on
dividends and price appreciation have
been very different. Price appreciation,
capital gains has been taxed at a lower
rate than dividends. And to the extent
that the dividend tax rate historically
has been higher, an investment strategy
at least in the 20th century in the US
that built around high dividend stocks
would have paid far more in taxes than
an investment strategy that investment
stocks with lower dividends more price
appreciation. The second is and you can
already see this especially in the
context of the previous graph. I assumed
you sold all your stocks at the end of
every year. Significance of that is your
capital gains taxes come to you only
when you sell. So if you have a longer
time horizon, you sell less frequently,
you will end up with less of a tax
effect than if you trade more. You turn
over your stocks some more. So what
kinds of stocks you're investing? How
often do you trade? To show the dividend
effect, here's what I did. You know, I
looked at, you know, earlier I showed
you what happens if you trade at the end
of every year and you invest in the
average stocks. Here I brought in two
other
portfolios. One of high dividend paying
stocks which is you know and the other
is of low dividend paying stocks. So
while taxes affect all three portfolios,
if you invest in stocks which paid
higher dividends than the average stock,
you end up with about 90,775.
If you invest in lower dividend stocks,
you end up with much more. If you pay if
you invest in non-ividend paying stocks,
you'd have made even more. So clearly
dividend yields mattered because
dividends were taxed at a much higher
tax rate than capital gains for the bulk
of this period.
So the tax effect matters and if you're
an investor in mutual funds the way this
shows up is in the difference between
your pre-tax returns and your post tax
returns and Morning Star over the last
decade or so has done a service has
provided a service to investors where
they compute the tax drag. The tax drag
is the effect on your annual returns
from taxes. So in this graph you see the
effect of the tax drag based upon
different kinds of investment
philosophies.
So let's look at all US funds. If your
time horizon is one year, the tax drag
is about 2.5%
every year. So if it looks like you're
making 11% of your funds, great. But
remember the one-year time horizon where
you liquidate your funds at the end of
every year, you're really making only 8
and a half%. That tax drag decreases if
you have a 5year or 10 year time
horizon. longer time horizons, lower
tech, but it persists.
I also broke um the this morning star
study also broke funds down into large
cap, midcap and small cap funds and the
tax drag tends to be larger at small cap
than large cap funds. It looked at
growth versus value funds and it found
that value funds perhaps because of
their focus on high dividend paying
stocks has a bigger tax drag especially
in the long term than growth funds. But
growth funds have a higher tax drag if
you have a little short time horizon.
But the bottom line is tax drags affect
returns and the actual returns you get
after taxes captures this. Now to bring
in the turnover effect, I go back to the
morning star data and I look at pre-tax
and after tax returns
for funds, mutual funds based on
turnover ratio. What's a turnover ratio?
It's the amount of trading they do
relative to the total value of the fund.
So if you have a $100 million fund and
you have 50 million in trading, your
turnover ratio is 50%. So this breaks
down funds from really low turnover to
really high turnover. There's a tax drag
in every single grouping, but the effect
the tax drag effect as a percentage is
much much greater when you have a lot of
turnover. So as an investor, the more
frequently you trade and the more
frequently your investment philosophy
requires it, the greater you expose
yourself to the tax track. The bottom
line is taxes are a part of life and
they affect your after tax returns. So
you have to factor that in and manage
taxes no matter what strategy or
philosophy adopt by doing what first is
to the extent you can. You want to keep
your trading to a minimum. Of course
it's going to vary across different
philosophies. Some will require more
than others but the less you trade the
better off you are. Second is you got to
factor in taxes when you're buying. You
decide to buy a company because it's
undervalued. You might want to look at
your tax rate and the kind of company it
is. Maybe it's a company with higher
dividends and that tax effect has to
factor into whether you buy the company
in the first place. You might have to
factor in when you sell because you get
taxed only when you sell on your capital
gains. You might decide to sell in a
year when your tax rate is low. The one
piece of advice I would offer you though
is don't invest purely to avoid taxes.
Not only does that put you in legal
jeopardy, but historically it's not been
a strategy that delivers returns for
investors.
Overall, if you look at the sum total of
what we've talked about in the session,
trading costs within the form of bid ask
spreads or price impact or the cost of
waiting or taxes all can cause your
after tax returns to be much lower than
what you observed on paper. That's why
so many strategies that look good on
paper don't look good in practice. I
hope you found the session useful and we
will return to this topic over and over
again in future sessions. Thank you very
much for listening.